we have some breaking news to bring you  now and the irish foreign minister simon  covney has been taken off stage by  officials that was during a speech in  belfast after a security alert  now the event organizer said a suspect  device was discovered in a hijacked van  driven into the car park of the venue  mr kovany left the stage in a hurry  and he later tweeted to say  in belfast with the hume foundation to  honor john and pat's legacy of peace for  all communities saddened and frustrated  that someone has been attacked and  victimized in this way and my thoughts  are with him and his family that's the  irish foreign minister there taken off  stage during a speech in belfast  after a suspect device found in a  hijacked vehicle